今日はちょっとねひとつお話ししたいことがあるんですよあのー僕の道あのいつも最後
のほうにエンディングが流れますこんな感じ
た
プって
ん
秋田はぁ
もう飽きたよもう飽きたわきたいつからこのエンディングしたんだろうけっこう昔だと
思うんですけども youtube の動画にはなぜかエンディングがあるというこの
流れが来たい僕も昔からちょっと動画にはエンディングをつけようと思って
エンディングをつけてたんですけどあのそろそろもうこのエンディングにも飽きてき
ました縫いぐらいから結構も2年間以上からこのエンディングでやってるんですけど
いやでも結構このエンディングに助けられたことが多いと思いませんなんかね面白く
ない動画もうこのエンディングの最後でこれゲスト番手打つことになってなんとうまい
ことまとまったこともあったのでこのエンディングにはとても感謝しております
ありがとうさせ屋2年間もずっとこのエンディングだとおもしろくねーと何か新しいに
的に変えようかなと思っております肇社長でセンディングカー僕の中の youtube
の宴
がもこれだっても決まっちゃってるんだよ作ろうと思えば作れると思うんですけども
なんでかパッとしないんですよ
この度皆様に肇社長の新しいエンディングを考えて頂けられないかと思っております
あー無理にとは言わないですよ無理にとは言えないですよメリー通りようなんですけど
もスネ日までなんか地下たねーなー
作ってやるかあぁみたいな人がいたらよかったら作ってみてくださいもう時間ある方で
いいのであーねちょっとね youtube ないんで結構難しくて長すぎた
長すぎるでちょっとっ
質問ねちょっと綺麗な方がいいしなんかこうみんなが終わりやすいような感じの
エンディングのほうがやっぱこうグッとなんですよっとしたら僕がこの2年間使ってき
たエンディングはイベント成功例だったのかなと思っておりますまあそんな難しいん
でぃんぐじゃなくていいと思うんですけどそれを使うかも知れませんしそれを犯行にし
て僕が新しく自分でエンディングを作るかもしれないところやまだ決めてない
ですけどもうちょっと動画のエンディングを奏するを変えようかと思っていた新年度で
もなった子は何だろうなポイントをちょっと入っておこうポイントとしてはシンブル
シンプルが大事ですあと七べく短い方がいいかもしれない猫という短さです多分10秒
神奈川関内それぐらいかもしれない字 bgm とか俺わかんねえぜエンディングって
でて作る直れ時短をよくわかんないでもだいたいそんなイメージだと思いますよ
ずっとね参考にしたいと思っているのでもし暇な方言ったらよかったら取らないん
でぃんぐ作ってみて下さいもちろん僕以外の人がエンディングに出てきたらもうわけ
わかんないことになっております五輪栗の下ネタ打ち込んでももう
いいエンディングが浮かばないのでちょっと皆さんの力を借りたいとほぼっております
差分で時間かかっちゃう人もいると思うので4月の初日まで募集しております
そしたら cg を使う方もいるかも知れません vfx を使い方もいるかもしれ
ないという方がいるといえば行動がを作るのに時間がかかっちゃうので10秒でもね
ちょっと時間を長めにとっております応募していただいたエンディングはひょっとし
たらこのと
動画で使うかも知れませんエンディング発表会ですねた分4月にはエンディング発表会
すると思うのでなんかユニークでも空エンディングがあるとこのチャンネルで発表さ
れるかもしれません食べエンディング作るような人は多分何かしら動画作ったことある
と思うので youtube のチャンネルを持ってると思いますそれでその自分の
チャンネルにアップロードしてください動画の名前をはじめした帳 ed にして今回
かゲット
公開にしてください
まるで僕が ed になったみたいなアップロードした動画の url 大下の応募
フォームから応募してみてくださいねクレームチャンネル名が僕のチャンネルで紹介さ
れるかも知れませんこれもたぶんね質問コーナーに近いような企画だと思っています
多分まともだの作ってくれるいったいういたら嬉しいですけどほぼ値段かどっちもねだ
とか化けわかんない奴が来るかもしれないんで
てい
そこもちょっと楽しみですサイズよぎり始め所蔵のエンディングを考えようの企画です
もしどうた造りに自信がある方はこのエンディングオススメだよっていうのがある方
明日の応募フォームから応募してみてくださいが叶いませんっていうこういったについ
ているからなかなか難しいと思うんですけども良かったらぜひをつくってみてください
とびっきりの年も出た綺麗なエンディングをお待ちしております
じゃーん
ああああああ